first of all let's talk about the timing
of these warrants because people have
sort of raised eyebrows and wonder
whether the warrants have been issued
just ahead of this conference but also
ahead of this important meeting between
Xi Jinping and Vladimir Putin what's the
reason behind the timing of these these
warrants being released many conspiracy
theorists uh we follow the evidence it
wasn't in our gift to decide when the
decision was rendered and my job was to
follow the evidence for the last one
year the team has been working very hard
we've been analyzing it and we presented
it to Independent judges of the ICC they
decided not me to issue a decision on
Friday it's simply the timing that
worked out and it's only right that when
bullets are flying and bombs are landing
and destruction and Mayhem is the staple
diet of too many of the most vulnerable
people the Lord needs to be on the front
lines and we're not going to wait or be
pedestrian when the law has to be seen
in action now you focus on these
warrants on the issue of children
specifically being deported from Ukraine
and into Russia we have on sky and
you've seen that firsthand orphanages in
her song entered by armed Russian
soldiers but the Russians say what
they're doing is not deporting children
but saving them from shelfa from a war
zone is there any defense for them well
the point is this that we have to follow
the evidence and my job when I submit to
the warrants under the statute is to was
to investigate incriminating and
exonerating evidence equally and it's
clear under the Fourth Geneva Convention
that children must be protected they
have to be looked after and made a
priority and firstly they have to be in
danger when you move them secondly if
you move them move them to other parts
of Ukraine which are safe presidents and
prime ministers have been heave in leviv
and all the rest of it and even if
whatever reason that's not immediately
possible go to a neutral Third Country
but what seems to have happened is
something quite different the first Port
of Call has been trying to make Russian
Ukrainian children Russia giving them
passports teaching them not Ukrainian
that they is their language but teaching
them Russian and that's not allowed so
to the extent there's any truth in the
argument that's being put forward
and we will keep our case under
continuous review as I would call upon
the Russian Federation not only to repa
repatriate and reunite children with
their mother country
um contact the United Nations Russian
Federation can contact the icrc contact
the third country and say well we have
no ulterior motive we just want the
welfare of the children to be first and
they can go back to Ukraine and safe
places but that ball really is in the
court of the decision makers in the
Russian Federation the ball that was in
ours is to independently and impartially
investigate that's what we did and then
the independent judges of the
international criminal court reviewed
that and they said yes there is a case
to answer and that's why we are where we
are today so there's a challenge for for
Russian authorities I think what's
called some surprise as well is that
you've gone to the very top Vladimir
Putin what is the evidence against him
and you've also been asked a number of
interviews what is the point in bringing
these charges against somebody who it's
unlikely will ever he's not going to
Hall to the Hague and I think you've
said that various characters who didn't
think that would happen to them it has
happened to them in your heart of hearts
Mr Khan do you expect to see Vladimir
Putin on trial in The Hague what I
expect is for myself to do my best to do
my job for the men and women of my
office to discharge their
responsibilities independently and
impartiality with full impartiality and
that remains fearlessly with courage
with independence with full objectivity
to relentlessly pursue the evidence to
separate fiction from fact this is what
we've done now you're quite right those
doomsters and gloomsters to use a phrase
that's perhaps overused thought that uh
it will it was a Fool's errand to set up
a yuga's love tribunal but we saw
president milosevic karadich and Milady
it's come before the court we saw the
same in with the former prime minister
of Rwanda for the 94 genocide John
cabanda his and habri in the African
Court Charles Taylor the list does go on
so those that think they have a free
pass or that there's no consequences
need to realize law is out there it's
not perfect it has a scattered record
over since the Holocaust because we've
all heard your viewers have heard the
promise of never again and we have heard
time and time again to the point of some
people getting Anita tised but this is
why the children that I saw
in the homes when I was on the
battlefield a couple of uh weeks ago in
the south of Ukraine they're not numbers
the cots were inhabited by babies by
young children uh by uh that have hopes
and dreams and they're not being brought
up now many of them under their own
language in their own schools but under
a Russian curriculum to be given Russian
passports adopted to strangers who are
Russian and that's not right and that
could be remedied if there was a will
and that's what the law requires one
last question we've heard some
surprising rhetoric for dimitro Medved
of the former prime minister saying that
he's so outraged by what he's hearing
from the likes of you and other
officials at the ICC uh that you should
look to the skies and watch out for
missiles that could be sent towards the
Hague what do you think of that kind of
talk well I think if we raise our gaze
we look for God and pray but we don't
are worried about those things look
these are I think everybody in a
position of responsibility should be
mature to realize that the world is in a
precarious situation it's a time for
leaders and mature judgment and I think
everybody should act under the under the
law and maturely and that's the only
advice one will give anybody you give it
to uh
any friend you'd give it to any any Foe
and the truth is the truth